for most of our history the human
population grew slowly until new
discoveries brought us more food and
made us live longer
in just a hundred years the human
population quadrupled
this led to apocalyptic visions of an
overcrowded earth
but the population growth rate actually
peaked in the 1960s
since then fertility rates have crashed
as countries industrialize and develop
the world population is now expected to
balance out at around 11 billion by the
end of the century
but the big picture conceals the details
let's look at one region in particular
sub-saharan africa
in 2019 it was home to a billion people
living in 46 countries
although its growth rate has slowed down
in the last few decades it's still much
higher than in the rest of the world
while some projections expect around 2.6
billion people others reckon with up to
5 billion by 2100
such growth would be a huge challenge
for any society but sub-saharan africa
is also the poorest region on earth
so is sub-saharan africa doomed and why
do the projections vary by 2.4 billion
people
as always it's complicated
sub-saharan africa is a made-up idea and
in many ways an unhelpful one botswana
is as far away from sierra leone as
ireland is from kazakhstan and they have
about as much in common
but without generalizing a little bit
this video would be an hour long
we've also talked to many different
scientists for this video and they
disagreed on a lot of things
mainly on how much fertility matters to
poverty
we've done our best to summarize our
research and what they told us but take
it with a grain of salt and check out
our sources where we discuss this in
more detail
okay let's zoom out to the global
perspective again
a few decades ago many countries in asia
were at a similar point to sub-saharan
africa today
large parts of the population were
living in extreme poverty and birth
rates were very high
take bangladesh in the 1960s the average
woman had seven children in her lifetime
twenty-five percent of them died before
they turned five and of the ones that
survived only one in five would learn to
read and write
life expectancy was around 45 and per
capita income was among the lowest in
the world
so beginning in the 1960s bangladesh
started a family planning program based
on three main pillars
one education helped to change women's
outlook
women with a higher education tend to
want fewer kids and become mothers later
in life
two
better health care lowered child
mortality leading to parents wanting
fewer children because they could expect
them to survive
three
field workers brought contraceptives
even to the remotest areas which drove
contraceptive use from eight percent in
1975 to 76 in 2019
together these measures greatly slowed
down population growth
in 1960 the average bangladeshi woman
had seven kids in 1995 four and in 2019
it was down to two
this also changed the country's
demographics and the economy
before many children were born but died
before they got to contribute to society
as far fewer kids die and fewer kids are
born things change
kids get an education and turn into
productive adults
the government was able to shift some of
their resources from lowering child
mortality to boosting the economy
by 2024 bangladesh is expected to
graduate from the category of least
developed countries to the status of a
developing economy
other asian countries like south korea
india thailand or the philippines have
gone through a similar process often
even faster
investment in health and education led
to lower birth rates which changed the
composition of the population and
enabled governments to boost the economy
why didn't the same thing happen
everywhere in sub-saharan africa
africa as a whole has made considerable
progress with childhood mortality but
especially in sub-saharan africa
education has improved slower than in
other parts of the world
and while in total contraceptive use has
doubled in the region since 1990 the
unmet need for modern contraception
among adolescents is still at about 60
percent the reasons for this are
complicated and it's impossible to give
a single answer here
africa is a big place with diverse
cultures and people but there are a few
main factors
many sub-saharan nations have suffered
under colonization until only a few
decades ago and had rough transition
periods towards independence the young
nations were often ethnically
heterogeneous and lacks unity
some areas have been repeatedly racked
by civil wars military conflicts or
suffered under unstable governments
which made it really hard to expand
infrastructure and healthcare
so africa had a worse starting point
than asia
foreign aid and how it was applied
especially during the cold war is also a
contentious issue
but this topic is too complex to
summarize in a few sentences so we'll
make a whole video about it in the
future
and lastly there are cultural aspects
that make talking about family planning
in the context of africa difficult
critics say that trying to bring
fertility down is an intrusion into
culture and tradition but not speaking
about an issue will not help solve it
not all of these things apply to every
country in the region we're talking
about 46 countries after all some of
them deeply troubled others already
flourishing all different and facing
unique problems
if population growth continues at its
present rate then sub-saharan africa
could grow to more than 4 billion people
by 2100
okay so what can be done
actually a lot
especially investment and aid that help
to build systems for education family
planning and healthcare
surprisingly small changes could have an
extreme impact
for example if women get a better
education and have their first child
just two years later in life
this tiny gap between this generation
and the next one would lead to 400
million fewer people in 2100 with 3.6
billion in total
[Music]
if education and family planning are
made available to every african woman
universal access to contraception makes
having kids a decision
if families get to choose how many kids
they want birth projections fall by 30
to 2.8 billion people
this isn't just theory there are already
examples that are reason for optimism
ethiopia the african country with the
second biggest population has made a lot
of progress in a relatively short amount
of time
improving health services led to a drop
in child mortality from twenty percent
to seven percent since nineteen ninety
and up to thirty percent of the annual
budget was invested in education and the
number of schools increased 25-fold over
two decades
so summarizing
there are serious challenges ahead but
they are far from unsolvable
sub-saharan africa does not need pity or
gifts but attention and fair investment
it's a region rich in resources culture
and potential
if things go right we'll see a
turnaround similar to the one we've seen
across most of asia in the last 30 years
[Music]